yeah so i'll talk about um one of my
favorite andy hacker stories it's called
key values
www.keyvalues.com so this is a site that
helps
engineers find teams that actually share
their values
so if you think about being an engineer
you're looking for a job often the
number one thing you care about is
salary you know location stuff like that
but
increasingly people want to work at
companies that actually share their
values right
these places that practice inclusion are
these places that have good work-life
balance are these places that are good
for parents
or maybe you want the opposite of all
these things uh regardless you can go to
key values
and basically select from a list of your
values and it'll pull up
some of the best tech companies that
align with the values that you want to
see oh my lord and i think
as yeah it's great and i think
probably the most inspiring thing about
it i mean look at some of the companies
that are on here github asana webflow
airtable y combinator and stakart uh but
this is all done by one person
her name is lin ty she's like the
prototypical
indie hacker she doesn't have any
co-founders she doesn't have any
employees
she's just sort of by herself in her
apartment working on the site
onboarding all the companies doing all
the sales and
it more than pays for a salary it's a
very profitable one-person company
and uh she actually
came from kind of outside of the tech
world she had nothing to do with tech
and she ended up getting her first tech
job at homejoy so home joy if you
remember was kind of the uber for home
cleaning back in the day
uh they raised very kind of money very
controversial there was a ton of money
they were
growing like a rocket ship they're also
burning a ton of money too
and they eventually kind of imploded and
while she was there she saw
that hey like she had this job as kind
of like a city opener
and she was very operational she was
kind of the glue that would tie the
different organizations you know have
sales talk to hr talk to the engineers
etc
but she just saw how well the engineers
are being treated and she's like oh this
is like a chump
job that i'm doing i need to learn how
to code and do my own thing
so she spent a year learning how to code
and at the end of it she was trying to
get her job herself
and she just didn't like how opaque the
process was you had to jump through so
many hoops as an engineer
before you could even talk to anybody in
the team and figure out like what's it
actually going to be like to work
at this place and so she had the idea to
create key values.com
and uh i think the first 10 or 20
companies she onboarded were completely
free
and then she ended up going through y
combinator herself but she had a very
indie hacker mindset she wasn't sure if
she wanted to go big she wasn't sure if
she wanted to become a billion dollar
unicorn
she really wanted something that would
just make her life better and the lives
of her customers better and so
at the end of yc she didn't do demo day
and the partners were not very happy
about it
they really wanted her to do demo day
but she didn't raise a dime i don't
think she even touched the money that
she raised
initially from yc uh she just started
doing sales
so to get a profile on keyvalues.com i
think it's five or ten grand a year
these companies are paying
and she does a little bit of upfront
work to sort of get them featured and to
make sure that their profiles
you know actually reflect the values
that they have as a company but after
that it's pretty hands off
and i interviewed her on eddie hackers
and she was making
i think 80 or 90 grand a quarter uh just
putting up these
these profiles for herself and she's
gotten quite a few acquisition offers as
well so
uh this is one of my favorite stories i
think it's like the way it's transformed
her life
has been pretty significant and all the
companies using it it's super valuable
for them because it's not just
uh sort of legion for hiring engineers
but also like the recruiters are putting
a link to their profiles
at the bottom of their outgoing emails
and it's forced them to be a lot more
thoughtful about
you know what kinds of places they want
to be as companies to work at
pretty great i mean when you look at
what they're actually asking people hey
do you want to be in a b2b or a b2c
company do you want one that's remote
okay something ideal for parents
work life balance one that is uh
you know design driven et cetera what
what a brilliant
simple idea and what a simple uh
brilliant
economic model you give the first 10
away for free then everybody's got to be
up there
it's hyper competitive and she under
priced it right if she's only charging
five or ten thousand a year
that's less than what you would pay when
you
uh convert one but but one yeah
uh developer and if you convert one
developer a year that makes it well
worth it and just
being able to state your values like
you're saying is just a great way to
have clarity inside your organization
it's a clarifying
tool for your organization right but
that's what i read into it was that
sales strategy
of under pricing daniel any thoughts on
uh key values
yeah i mean it's interesting i think
there's um
to me i feel like there's this
interesting migration
of like 1.0 of internet review sites to
kind of the 2.0
um and you know glassdoor comes to mind
is like the way people currently decide
uh you know where to work and you get a
sense from you know glassdoor just how
big this type of thing can get
but as these companies get big like you
have you have all these weird stories
you hear about yelp and you hear about
amazon too the reviews being distorted
they hold companies hostage all sorts of
weird stuff start happening
and that i think devalues the currency
of the review
um yes and and and and so i think
there's
you can actually see across every
industry be it job selection which is
what key values is doing
i imagine this will happen to product
search you know in the future
as people lose faith in amazon reviews
um and i imagine you know this has kind
of already happened with
yelp uh reviews kind of meaning less and
less over time especially compared to
google reviews
um there are there are all sorts of
these i think new platforms that will
hopefully
provide i think the interesting thing
for her to reason is as she becomes
successful how does she ensure
things are high quality and trustworthy
because there does seem to be
the economic incentive is you know at
some point i think
going potentially going to compromise
the quality of the reviews so
having kind of rigid founder grip
strength there i think will matter quite
a bit and wouldn't surprise me if two
three four years from now
we see this becoming kind of more
impactful than glassdoor
i am in love with a new product it's
called chart hop it's new to me i mean
it's been around to be honest
many of you are already using it you can
go see it at charthop.comtwist
when you want to create an
organizational chart for your company
this is a critical moment that shows you
are venture fundable
if you know these are my top executives
these are my units
this is my group that's going to do
customer support this is my marketing
group
this is my cto this is uh finance this
is operations
well you can do all that and make like
some cruddy little
drawing with like some painting program
or sketching program or
you can make your own org chart that has
all the data
around all of your people we call this
people data we call it human capital in
the industry
but in this org chart you can also put
in performance reviews right into the
org chart and
you centralize all the data there and
you can build a nice agile adaptable and
inclusive team because you can look and
say hey
where's my diversity how am i doing with
building out my organization
and at the core a startup is about
people we all know that
go to charthop.com twist and try it out
today you're gonna get 600
credits i talked to the founders i
talked to the marketing team over there
and i said just give people hundreds of
dollars
just come over the top and throw like
just grab a handful of hundies and throw
them at the audience well here it is
charthop.com
twist six hundred dollars in credits go
and get it
set up now basically that 600 is going
to cover your first five employees on
the platform
which makes it no brainer to get started
go ahead and check out chart
hop c h a r t h o p dot com twist
for six hundy get it now because i don't
know if they're gonna keep that offer up